here's a story from fox news aoc
questions if capitol police officer
tried to put her in a
vulnerable situation quote he was
looking at me with a tremendous amount
of anger and hostility
they say rep aoc wondered aloud monday
whether a capital police officer
who barged into her office to direct her
to a safe location during the january 6
riot was actually trying to protect her
or not
saying like so many other communities in
this country just that presence doesn't
give you a clear signal if you're safe
or not
so so the situation did not feel okay
aoc has four weeks said she thought she
was going to die that day
she said the officer had anger and
hostility in his eyes
and she questioned whether or not he had
been trying to put her
in a vulnerable situation still she said
she wasn't sure and was trying not to
pass judgment
the new york democrat detailed on
instagram live monday night the series
of events that led her to question the
officer's motives
at the time she realized riders had
breached the capital and she hid in her
office fearing for her life
she says that uh a little after 1 pm she
heard banging on the door
like someone was trying to break down
the door fearing it was a rioter she hid
in her bathroom
she said she heard repeated yells of
where is she through the door hinged
i see this white man in a black beanie i
have never been quieter in my life
all of a sudden i hear my staffer gl out
hey it's okay come out
when i come out this man is a capital
police officer he was looking at me with
a tremendous amount of anger and
hostility
things weren't adding up she continued
she said her staff read also not known
if the officer was there to help us or
hurt us
that is how aggressive the situation was
in that moment we couldn't tell if this
was a good situation or a bad situation
well i'll tell you the first thing i'll
say is
aoc has no conflict experience what did
she do she went to boston university or
whatever
she did work at a bar though i mean you
break out i mean
yeah a little bit but yeah you know
she's she so i i can respect that she
was genuinely scared 100 percent
but i i am a little uh uh mildly
perturbed
yeah at this story where you have a cop
rushing to her
because he knows she's famous i'm
assuming but
this cop goes to her office knocks on
the door probably loudly i mean there's
a riot going on
and he says where is she she assumes all
these negative things about the cop who
actually saved her and protected her and
told her to go to a different building
yeah i don't know so what is the exact
complaint
here from her just that he was too angry
or he was harsh in his tone or did he
say something to her i don't understand
yeah he was harsh in his tone
and you know uh interestingly i'm i'm
not going to put all the heat on aoc for
this one
she was telling a story about how she
felt and how she perceived it yeah i get
it that's fine
the issue is how the media is latching
onto it to turn it into a culture war
issue that's a very good point and then
michael tracy called it emotional
manipulation i even said earlier i
wouldn't call it manipulation
actually you know michael tracy is right
but i don't think it's you know what she
did when she told the story was more
about promoting herself
and getting more attention because she
is a master at turning the story into a
story about aoc
now it's it's nearly a month later and
the capital riot story is
all about aoc and ted cruz almost had
her killed
and now she's hiding in her bathroom and
there are a lot of questions we got to
bring up about this story but i don't
look you look like you're gonna say
i mean it was an intense moment it would
be interesting to know if this was
before and after the police
shot and killed someone but you know
that officer probably thought he was
risking his life and it was a very
intense moment so i think that's worth
factoring in here too and as you said
what's what's the story here there's
none it's a nothing burger nothing
happened
it's a personal story that again the
mainstream media and alexandria
ocasio-cortez even though she's not
really
uh you know obsessing about it and
pushing it like the mainstream media is
she knows what she's doing on the same
hand as well she knows the attention
this is going to get
this is going to garner she knows the
talking points and
uh essentially i mean we're talking
about it right right yeah exactly when
it's a perfect story because it's going
to get
it's going to get both sides worked up
you're going to have all the boomer cons
you just love
uh picking over every single one of the
aoc's sentences and
and um freaking out about it and granted
like there's subject matter there but at
some point when you argue with a fool
there are two and you just have to
ignore some of this yeah this is you
no i hear you on that too because the
media keeps shoving it in our face
i want to tell you exactly why i decided
to talk about this story because
it's precisely how much i don't care
about it and it embodies
perfectly what i see almost like every
day
in news this was trending this story was
trending this morning
the young turks dedicated a live segment
to this like pathetic michael tracy and
i'm like
that's is that's what they are that's
what they do that's what these
these news outlets and even the young
turks do they
they pile on to the drama when i saw
that
aoc was you know this live stream you
know what i thought huh
that's it yeah you know i thought a
white guy in a black beanie
hmm i just mentioned you i pictured you
okay it was it was me i was the cop the
whole time
that was her actually no no but here's
the point beautiful there are stories
like this
all the time where it's like i see
someone you know like someone from the
squad tweet something
and i'm just like i just see it i go huh
how is that impacting anything she told
the story
it was her feelings in in in the moment
she told it the way she felt it was good
for her it generated a lot of press
congratulations
and then when michael tracy criticizes
her and he's just some dude on twitter
i'm not trying to be disrespectful he's
a journalist he's got a twitter account
it turns into a major story where
everyone's picking it up
listen what we need to focus on and we
need a media to call out say
biden's 43 executive orders instead
what we get is drama between
twitter accounts yeah yeah get used to
that though i mean that gets views
that's more interesting who cares about
executive orders
and who in the media is going to talk
about them yep you know what i would
like to point out i think
maybe congress should have combat
training now
maybe maybe it should be important if
you're going to run for office and you
get voted in that you need some sort of
military training you remember when when
politicians used to duel each other
yes yeah i mean none of us remember it
we weren't there
but uh historically yes right about that
in a history
book or two i was watching back to the
features on the other day and i was back
to feature three
where you know biff or whatever no no
that was his name buford that was his
name
he's gonna you know shoot at noon or
whatever old cliche
and i was like yeah it's kind of like we
used to be like
these these high noon 10 paces duels in
the wild west
like we used to do this all the time
yeah like
politicians literally would just shoot
each other dude if you if you ran into
someone with your horse they'd just
shoot you when they what do you remember
about you're playing too much red dawn
redemption
actually do you guys remember about 10
years ago
uh it was either senator or congressman
who yelled who yelled you lie at obama
and they were like i don't remember who
but the entire media was like this is
unprecedented this level
of incivility i was like they used to
shoot each other yeah like they used to
shoot each other
but yeah it's horrible and obviously
it's it's a better place to be in where
yelling is bad
um and uh you know you're that far
removed from violence but unfortunately
it does seem we
are returning there in a lot of ways
tensions have been escalating it's kind
of crazy
when you look back a hundred years ago
uh hundreds of years ago how
like they didn't really value their own
lives all that much yeah like i
would want to duel someone because i
i've grown quite fond of living yeah
have we talked i feel like we've talked
about this before like people were just
or maybe i've had this conversation with
someone else or maybe it's the way the
past was depicted or the machismo that
people had but
yeah folks were a lot more willing to
take risks that would result in their
life ending yeah now or not
i mean maybe maybe this i've got about
three teeth left so
it's probably about time anyway so
there's a few things that i wanted to
uh you know highlight with the story one
is should we have politicians who aren't
going to be scared
and hide in the bathroom while their
staffers
stand guard for them you know what i
mean so like
i don't blame her for being scared she
didn't know what's going on and she's
you know
what's that oh sorry sorry yeah i mean i
don't i don't blame her she was scared
um i guess is this sort of back to ian's
point about some kind of military
training for for congress people or
i don't know if we need uh congress
people to have military training
like that yeah but there there's a
there's a funny issue in the story where
she says her staffer
told her it was safe to come out
implying that she was hiding in the
bathroom and left her staffer out in the
front oh
i get that i hear you on that point yes
yeah
so so the issue i'm bringing up is
are these the people who are going to be
voting our kids into war yeah that's a
very good you know who are going to be
no they yeah exactly they should be
armed they should learn how to handle
weapons have some sort of combat right
there
be armed if they're going to be working
at the capitol you know i think that's a
really good point not necessarily
because we want uh
not necessarily because we expect that
the capital is going to be continually
attacked though again you know
hope for the best prepare for the worst
that said if if you are going to be
sending people to fight in wars and you
are going to be regulating guns you
should probably have some knowledge of
combat
i say i say let's go a step further if
you want to fight a war you go fight it
if the politician wants to start one
bring your sons bring yourself go out
there just like the kings did
the kings back in the day obviously you
know as you said
way back way back in the day if they
wanted to fight a war they would
literally put their brothers their
sisters their whole family on the front
line they were the ones leading the
charge
and why not bring that back let's even
bring back dueling if they want to do it
themselves voluntarily i mean
to me that's uh that's a that's a you
know solution that a voluntarist would
really like
you need to like sign a contract like
hereby duel the problem with that is
someone could be coerced into signing
something or they could yeah they don't
like it and then murder somebody
i definitely like to do oh sorry no i
was going to say there was a period
where the kings
stopped doing that and then i don't know
if you guys ever seen the movie the
patriot man
i i reference the patriots all the time
where cornwallis is like
you know stop killing my officers could
you imagine the chaos of
you know no officers on the battlefield
oh like you can't you can't kill those
guys
yeah just kill the little poor people
yeah it's really really horrible
and i i'm not definitely not a fan of of
dueling but i hear you guys very much on
the fact or on the this idea that
there should be more of a a cost to the
the people
waging these wars or pushing the country
into them that there isn't i mean it's a
cost that your average person pays or is
more liable to pay and they just don't
to me it's also kind of awkward to see
the people who create one of the worst
humanitarian crisises
in the world specifically with yemen
selling weapons to saudi arabia and
allowing that
telling us about uncivility and how rude
people are and how violent protests are
i mean
the two don't really add up when you
really look at it from that perspective
yeah i mean you look at the fact that uh
boeing had like a 580 billion dollar
contract servicing the f-12s that were
being used to bomb yemen by the saudi
arabian government well no no no
the u.s saudi coalition yeah that are
working together
in tandem yeah bombing the crap out of
mainly the hootsie areas which of course
is creating the worst humanitarian
uh you know crisis according to the
united nations so here's what i want to
do
you know we're talking about this the
capital right again i'm just kind of
like
it's been a month why is it still coming
up and it's so long as they want to milk
it for all it's worth
and then run these segments i'll just be
like can we get that dude who's bar
burnt down in the minneapolis riots
on the tv as well because i'm i'm all
down so like aoc told their story all
right i respect that congrats you know i
hear you i hear you it was probably
traumatic you've never experienced
something
before i must be must be crazy and sorry
it happened to you um how about we make
room on the stage for the the
the businessman who you set up a sports
bar
it was his dream he's a firefighter and
then it got destroyed by these rioters
how come we didn't have this massive
news cycle for this guy and it was
incumbent upon
you know independent news channels and
and social media to promote this guy to
get him the support he needed
well they're going to be talking about
this for four years minimum exactly this
is their 911. this is their
harbor this is the event that they're
going to be milking until
i don't even want to say when but i
remember even driving cows come home
yeah
i love it i remember just even today
driving and listening to npr and they
had a cia guy
of course who was talking about the
dangers of insurrection
domestically and specifically going on
about how we need to take down trump we
need to charge him with as much as we
can because he represents a strong guy
and there's an ideology that we need to
fight domestically
and it was bomb it was just
mind-boggling sitting back driving and
watching and
seeing a cia guy who who fought off
insurgents
in the middle east now trying to
implement some of those policies
inside of the united states domestically
and when you look at biden and the
people he surrounded himself with
especially
uh with the laser-like focus that the
intelligence agencies under him
according to john brennan are going to
be focusing now on the libertarians and
on the nativists
we're headed towards a situation that's
not going to be clearing up any time and
this is why they're going to be talking
about this
insurrection for at least
at least four years i'm surprised we're
still not milking 911
uh just like rudy giuliani did we
basically are with the people yeah
exactly with the patriot act all
the same laws are in effect and all the
same overreactions are still in place
you know we're still fighting in the
middle east these wars have continued
after afghanistan and even today we got
news and information that you know
germany is pushing the united states to
stay
in longer and most likely the other
information and other reports we're
getting in today
is that the withdrawal that was planned
from afghanistan is not going to happen
oh geez
so the the trooper yeah so well so
that's what a shock that is
right the establish the these listen you
know you know why i love the game stop
story
is that for once you have a clear path
to uniting
left and right on an issue they agree on
and against the establishment elites who
propagate these wars
and then we see this drama pop up which
is the distraction in my opinion on
purpose
to get us off topic to focus on stupid
drama that doesn't mean anything well
and it's funny because they go on and on
about how
it was trump who riled up these tensions
and i think it was even claimed that ted
cruz was responsible aoc insinuated that
earlier
stated that aoc said that yeah yeah
which is
so insane and their whole argument is
well they propagated misinformation
that allowed for tensions to become so
high that people
were willing to attack the capital it's
like well what about all the lies the
media told to get us into these
conflicts in the middle east how many
people have died as a result of that and
how many of them are on camera
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time